what's the objective for us the  objective is to document and share the  best practices of building world-class  companies we do that by building  world-class companies and documenting it  and then we share it and the key point  of sharing is like we share it so that  everybody can have it and i just in my  bones believe that the only thing that  makes the world better is  entrepreneurial businesses and so the  more business owners we can equip with  the skills and lessons that were very  difficult and painful for us to learn  then the more good businesses will be  out there and even if none of them ever  work with us like we'll die and it won't  matter and it's okay and we're happy to  just help people out and we're good with  that if you like this video you want to  see the original longer 4 version of  what this was taken from go to the  youtube channel and you'll see the rest  of it